bow how are you this morning I'm good
man how are you I'm good I wanted to ask
you also about the Olli coverage uh is I
said Olli would love it over the top
like you know we were we're debating if
it was too much coverage of Olli and I
said well Ali would love this your
thoughts of the Olli coverage including
the mothership with nine and a half
hours of coverage I mean I might get a
little bit of time off a radio today for
us long I really played it a lot just
right as long as you well Vic um but I
do I agree with you I think that I leave
certainly wanted to be over the top
because I Lee himself was over the top
and I think it's a disparate range of
people who are going to be there and I
think that I'll leave would also like
family what they prefer we have to
remember that I leave is not always the
both consistent ideologically so like
you look up and you're like wait a
minute Orrin Hatch is going to be
speaking at mom Ali's funeral
yes apparently Orrin Hatch with his
favorite politician for example like
this is this is a guy she loves this is
a yeah oh yeah I do think that something
like this absolutely what I leave would
walk that heavyweight champion they call
them champ for a reason because they see
themselves in that way and this is going
to be a whole going fitting of a
champion boxer social impact what's the
lead with Muhammad Ali I think it's
social impact and I mean and in the
boxer part is very important I don't
think that we could lose sight of the
fact that he's the greatest heavyweight
of the greatest era of heavyweights that
we've ever had so I mean it's a big deal
in that way but the social relevance I
think is more because the Vietnam War is
a defining part of that period of
history in the face of the opposition of
the Vietnam War which time is borne out
is in eyes of many the morally correct
side alley is the face of that so like
you can't talk about that era of
American history a very significant air
of American history without talking
about Muhammad Ali if you would have
said Ali in the late 60s and a Jay
Simpson at the same time hey one of you
is going to be one of
most beloved athletes of all time and
the other one is going to be in prison
and accused of a double murder what do
they have nothing that's a crazy way to
put it I had never quite thought of it
quite that way in the judge position
where Jose says they did everything he
possibly could for people to like you
fit now he is perhaps the most despised
man by the majority in this country and
Muhammad Ali whose reputation is doing
the opposite is now the one who dies and
is absolutely beloved like this would
have been the funeral Oh Jay Simpson
would have had if OJ Simpson died in May
of 1994 by it's crazy to think of what
do we learn from this why are we
obsessed with there's still 21 years
later focus a whole lot of people can't
get over the fact that OJ Simpson may
have gotten away with murder like that's
the one that seems to be the thinking
I'm fascinated by how like this is the
one time that somebody killed his wife
and got away with it if this is the one
that like really charges people up still
like there's a real visceral anger um
when it comes to OJ Simpson and it
relates to this trial but on the other
end it's also like a really fascinating
story like the trial itself I think we
talked about this uh spring in the era
of cable news and everything else but we
also can't ignore the fact it was
legitimately compelling theater like it
was really really interesting to watch
on a number of levels and OJ was almost
just a side player because you never
heard his voice throughout the Trop yeah
wait that was reality TV when it was
really real now you're watching a life
lives hang in the balance here right in
front of you and how it played out you
know it's like it's a it was a Broadway
show well it also was like the people
you meet in Los Angeles right like if
you can serve people who don't live in
Los Angeles time around Los Angeles
these are the wild sets of people that
come together around all that Hollywood
stuff right through the portal into this
world like the idea of Kato Kaelin like
people forgot [ __ ] okay at this point
like the basic notion of Kato Kaelin
existing and everybody who was in like
wide up around him and didn't have the
star turn like that the city full of
people who want to be stars and how many
of them accidentally became stars
because it is Jose Simpson trial I did
just it was such a fascinating snapshot
into the strange world of Los Angeles
California but you also have everything
it's
this confluence of race celebrity police
you throw that all together and boy that
sets a combustible cocktail right there
especially when those things are
evaluated superficially which is what I
think happened actually during the trial
like to think about Ezra's bill but I
think it's so important is that you have
three hours of footage before you get to
the murderer let alone to trial because
there's so much that you have to setup
about how you get to the point of this
trial being such a big deal and it's a
it's a fascinating look at I really
think truly at American history the
first episode on oj um and him like
growing up in San Francisco I just found
that to be as interesting is anything
else that was in the film because we
don't really know that much like we pick
up OJ Simpson he's the biggest star in
sports and then even that the episode
that's about that is really really
interesting about how OJ Simpson as a
salesman was constructed in the ideas
behind into things that people feel
comfortable saying in the film like then
we wind up getting to the murder like I
think they're people if you are under
the age of 30 like I'm only 35 so I
didn't really witness this you know as
it was contemporary but the hardest part
to make people understand is what a big
deal OJ Simpson was an FX theory you
could really get a glimpse of that the
best thing about this 34:30 is you look
at it and you're like oh this is why
this guy was such a big deal but I also
go we're talking about Monty Jones of
the mothership I also go back to the
Olly OJ Simpson Ali's scared white
America at least a portion of white
America Oh Jay Simpson didn't like white
America embraced OJ Simpson at that same
time so I go back to those two I just
find it you know fascinating you know
that here we are covering those two in
the same weekend but I think white
America said OJ yeah he's he seems like
a nice man we're going to well welcome
him into our living room here well they
went past literally like the most
interesting thing is if anybody's ever
like come folks actually transcending
race Oh take aim really really really
really really close in the parts in the
film that talk about how you know how he
saw himself as being set apart like the
FX series at the whole I'm not black I'm
owed a lot but he actually believed that
like he really got to a point where he
thought that he could pull that off
where Ali
on the other hand was demanding that you
acknowledge his blackness and respected
at every turn and now we get to where we
are at the end and we've got people
trying to kind of ignore the blackness
of Mohammed Ali to make you pay for
universal figure and Jose black is he
ever gonna be you know getting out of
that now
like here you are like it for 1994 all
on the black portion of oj attempted
life began as hard as he tried to run
from it he never ever could but isn't
there a part in the documentary where
they wanted to make okay more black so
they went in and exchanged photographs
in his house to take down the white
photographs of friends and put up black
photographs yes because the thing the
thing about a second day at the FX
series at that part also it was less
about making oj black as it was hiding
the fact that oj did not associate with
but a handful of black people like he
just completely divorced themselves from
the black experience in that way for all
the people in his house with some
exceptions we're all white people right
like this is all it was and so the I
said if you're going to say hey oj
simpson has been treated poorly but
insisted because he flat it already
self-aware with the jurors when you get
in there is not perfect but about white
people on the wall specifically a bunch
of white women and no black foot that
was today no hold oh we got lifted we D
got changes which the most shocking
moment not all this who like in the film
like I don't even want to ruin some of
the ones that just like this is the most
amazing thing that I have ever heard but
I think the part that will shock a lot
of people is getting a federal look at
the history of the law fantasies part
like before we're talking about the
Rodney King stuff and everything else
even before Watts would likely lead up
to the Watts ride I think that stuff
that people are going to look at and be
like oh okay I didn't realize it was
like that because I think that people
have to picture in their head of
California being this liberal paradise
people you know associate the term
liberal but a whole lot of other things
but the history of people making that
relocation to Los Angeles it's almost
like an American tale right like the
Disney movie there no Captain America
the streets are filled with cheese and
then they get there and they're like yo
where's the key like there's a lot there
with LA for people like OJ's
we had moved from the south to Los
Angeles for Nia
and I think the people are going to
learn a lot about the history that
they've forgotten part of the history of
this country that I think it'd be very
helpful for if you don't have the Rodney
King verdict is there a different
outcome is there different reaction to
OJ Simpson a different backdrop that
Johnnie Cochran and his team would have
used been able to use no I don't think
so and the reason is the the Rodney King
riots um I think they informed a larger
nation of what the situation was but
people have been living that everyday
like they didn't need that verdict their
verdict was just like okay we're tired
of but I think if you don't have that
verdict pretty much all the
circumstances still the same like NWA
did after police in 1988 I think
operation hammer comes right after that
um like that was all the way there it
had always been there so like you didn't
need something specific like Rodney came
for the Watts Riots to happen either
right like you didn't need it in that
way so I think that swirled with people
for so long that no matter what happened
Cochran could have sold it the same
exact way and also let's not forget yet
a helping hand from a really incompetent
prosecution the one thing that doesn't
know I mean when people talk about this
and the aftermath is those dudes at a 20
point lead and blew the gate I guess
that's what the prosecution did up there
we got a 20 point lead and they blew it
again are you comparing them to the
Oklahoma City Thunder oh man they're
close man they're close like I don't
even know if that's right I did more
like the Houston Oilers to Buffalo Wow
like I did well why would you go look at
that I mean I think that most people are
pretty confident that Oh Jay something
killed those people I think you'll watch
the documentary and you'll come come
away with it with the understanding that
OJ Simpson probably killed those people
outside a good friend of mine who saw it
and we both had the same conclude that
after watching that I'm sure than ever
that OJ's doesn't killed those people
and I am sure than ever that a not
guilty verdict was correct as those
Joker's just blew a 20-point lead yeah I
I just curious if they if he had an
accomplice
you know thanked I think he did it but
I'm not curious about that if he had a
chance to want you think OJ's gonna
watch this get a chance to watch this
y'all know how what kind of
accommodations that he's got in there
he has all the time in the world watch
seven half-hour documentary a big pop I
think that owed a ego is so sizable that
he would watch it just to see himself on
the screen because he'll be able to
watch that and see the stuff from the 60
to 70 feel like man look at look at me
right there because he's so striped like
I think it's really really important for
people to see it and to remember when
you watch this people didn't just make a
Jay Simpson into a star he was a living
breathing phenomenon and absolutely
should have been and he did everything
right to like to see clothes to help
with his teammates I have to run for
2000 yards any thanking everybody else
on the team and never talking about
himself
I mean pulled a hell of a roof over
American have it all come crashing down
when you know you might have killed
somebody
Thank You Bo good to talk to you have a
good weekend all right buddy guys be
good all right bomani Jones trick show
weekday mornings on audience